now that the main lore videos are
finished like story ending in main
characters i wanted to delve into the
lesser known content missions that
aren't required and maybe only take an
hour or two of your time and i wanted to
start this off with the perales side
quest
at first i didn't like this side quest
and thought it was all right but after
really digging into the quest and
playing it a second time i realized it's
better than i could have ever expected
this quest involves a married couple
named jefferson and elizabeth perales
and what was a simple job turns into a
breach of privacy and mind control
spoiler warning for the whole perilous
questline and one of the endings
to do this quest we have to complete
ghost town which is talking to rogue
meeting with pan am and ending it with
interrogating hellman
after about a day or so in game we'll
receive a call from someone who has a
job for us and that we were the
recommended merc she doesn't provide
info on her name or what the job
is saying that all will be explained at
the meetup location in the back alley is
a bodyguard and a car and inside that
car
is jeff and elizabeth jeff is in the
running for future mayor of night city
we can see this unfolding game as a news
report talks about the current mayor
lucius ryan and his unexpected
death sources say he died in his sleep
and that the rest of his term will be
fulfilled by his close friend and deputy
mayor weldon holt
until the next election where holt will
run against former district attorney
jefferson perales so why does this
couple need our help i doubt a merc
would be really good at running ad
campaigns
they believe that lucious ryan's death
wasn't an accident and that something
else is going on
the media states it was a cardio implant
malfunction but there was a cyber
psychoattack just days before this and
that there's maybe a connection
jefferson gives us a bd shard of the
attack and in this 1 minute 30 second
clip is from the perspective of a guard
at city hall who meets with an ncpd
officer and then is stabbed shortly
after
while watching the bd we can get some
other clues lucius ryan was talking to
weldon holt about his upcoming speech
and that he needed a break mentioning if
his room at the red queen's race is
ready
holden and his bodyguards seem to have
left at the perfect moment right before
the attack
could be some possible betrayal going on
the cyber psycho seem to also be packing
some serious cyberware how does someone
like this get their hands on these
implants
this is all we can really pull from the
bd hold seems like a suspect and it's
possible that he knew about this attack
but it's not enough evidence to make a
clear decision but we do have info on
the cop river and red queen's race
with this info we talk to river and see
his side of the story and why his timing
is so perfect we meet with river and see
a small argument between him and his
detective about dropping the lucious
rhine case
awfully strange from river we learn more
about this cyber psycho he said that he
had a meeting with the mayor that day
he was a suspicious target to the ncpd
so they took him in but either him or
someone else must have got him out as
apparently he got lost on the way to the
precinct which is how he ended up at
city hall we gave river some details on
red queen's race and says that he may
have a guy who can help us tell its
location as well as a person who hired
the psycho his employer is christine
markhoff who owns a tech store and
cherry blossom market she says one day
he came in all decked him with new gear
for some unknown person he also had a
tendency to spout nonsense at the market
about lucius reine and his terrible
policies
next up is river ci who ends up trying
to run but is caught by river
neil gives us the location and the info
that red queen's race was closed shortly
after
mayor's death sounds like he died at red
queen's race and not at home like the
media stated but we need to confirm our
suspicion first red queen's race is
covered in animal guards and is hidden
only accessible by an elevator in a
small container as opposed to lighting
up the building on site if we sneak
around we can interrogate the boss of
the club the animals were paid to wreck
the club and wait for their payment of
eddies and they were paid by weldon holt
waldenhalt knew about
his death and paid off the animals to
destroy the club in evidence a recording
on the computer shows detective han
on the scene talking to someone
describing the scene and saying that
he'll twist the story to say that he
died peacefully we can find his true
death by going to the bd and putting it
on our heads which electrocutes us
someone spiked ryan's bd at the club and
when he was dead detective han covered
it up while hulk paid the animals to
destroy the club we confront han about
this information but he gives us nothing
sadly we never really discover who did
it but there's lots of evidence that
does point to holt wanting ryan dead for
his seat as mayor at least it's enough
for river to open up the case again
we returned to perales with the info we
got and explained that either the ncpd
covered it up or we have a strong
suspicion it was halt either one
completes the quest with perales
thanking us for helping him as a
response to this information they do
plan on keeping an eye on holt a bit
more and upping their security at home
this would be the end of the quest and
could be seen as a segue into river's
questline in a possible future romance
but
about two days later we receive another
phone call from jefferson this time when
we arrive it's just the married couple
and they don't look too happy
no i'm not sucking anyone's dick just so
they can [ __ ] me in the ass
apparently there was a break-in
according to jeff he woke up and heard a
noise he saw a figure in his room
goes for his gun shoots him then passes
out almost immediately after
once again we have to ask why us if
anything river should be on this case
but jeff prefers as he calls it tried
and tested contacts which is why he
called us
of course like any good detective we
asked jeff some questions for more
context
from our questions we know that the
intruder was wearing a possible mask or
implant but no confirmation on his face
this intruder apparently caused no
damage to the house and took no
valuables with him as we know jeff
collapsed shortly after firing his
weapon but he awoke the next morning in
his bed with a killer headache
we also know from the last quest that
the perales couple was going to hire
more security if anything
they should have seen the intruder but
they claim they've seen no signs of a
break in their gunfire and claim to hear
nothing going on throughout the night we
could question the security on the
matter but they're nowhere to be seen
this is because they were told to step
out for the day to give us a chance to
investigate on our own without
interruptions the security team is from
a company called
ssi very well known and respected as
they have hundreds of customers and have
been in business for the last 15 years
the company was also recommended by an
acquaintance of jeffs from this we can
come up with a couple theories this
intruder either wanted to steal
something but was caught early in the
crime by jeff or he didn't want to steal
anything at all and wanted to kill
someone and security claims they saw
nothing which i find quite hard to
believe while not anything concrete it's
a start so let's keep this info in mind
jeff has to bolt to a meeting so it's
just us and elizabeth inside the home
she gives us a tour of the home and we
try to find some clues
on the table we can see a campaign
poster for jeff and a shard with this
campaign speech on the bottom floor
jeff wants to end mega corporate
influence in night city he runs ads
without any payment from them and he
also wants a truly independent city and
an end to the mega corporate rule
even stating he wants an end to
decisions being made by people who
haven't experienced night city and just
sit in an office all day for his first
year as mayor he plans to create 20 full
and 30 partial scholarships with the aim
of funding the 200 most gifted students
of the city every year so far he sounds
like a solid candidate holt's got some
competition from the looks of the food
they seem to be working hard on the
election so much that they can only get
fast
food as it's quick on the table we see a
laptop and a shard the shark talks about
an
avian extermination program this was
made in response to the growing outbreak
and the city council determined that the
most effective way to cleanse the city
was killing all avian life within 18
miles of the city
limits avian is another word for birds
they are mass killing birds i don't
normally browse the sky so i could be
wrong but i haven't actually seen any
birds in game so maybe this is why and
even if there were birds in the game it
really wouldn't be the safest
environment for them considering all the
pollution in the city but the question
is why is this here
this could just be notes for jeff that
he would use in his feature maybe this
is something holt agrees with or even
crafted himself and is gonna use this
info against him in the election the
laptop doesn't really seem like his
personal computer maybe it's just the
on-the-go laptop from when he's
traveling and doesn't have access to his
own personal setup on the computer is a
file for his campaign ad and honestly if
a runner for the mayor of my town
doesn't shoot his computer and notes
mid-ad
i don't want him definitely playing the
role as the people's choice as most
citizens
in night city are carrying weapons and
it's hard to go a couple blocks without
some crime in the city so he's appealing
to the audience
as for the messages it's a conversation
between jeff and some of his associates
it seems that jeff didn't want to do the
ad for that campaign but his advisors
wanted him to anyway so he could appeal
to that audience it seems like jeff
prefers the traditional methods of
politics we also see a message from the
chief of security mr wallace who talks
about parallels hiring us for the
previous quest and how he completely
disapproves of it the third message is
from eric his chief advisor and is in
disagreement in not accepting money from
the corpse
as we said jeff's goal was a non-mega
corp funded campaign it would go against
what he preaches if he took the money
from them but eric believes that it's
the best way to keep the campaign afloat
which is also true the final message is
from jeff to eric this time in a
separate email chain
jeff originally wanted this lia woman
fired she's the one that jeff emailed
about the ad and the disapproving of
making it in the first message
eric is confused as he doesn't remember
this conversation jeff shuts this down
and passing into something
imaginative next door is a hallway and a
couple rooms to the right is a personal
office with a laptop
this seems to be elizabeth's personal
office kind of small but at least she
has a room to herself she also has a
couple messages on her laptop as well
the first is from her daughter so she
seems like sochi is studying abroad in
europe and wants to help her family with
the election
elizabeth doesn't want her to stress
about them or help them though however
sochi's too smart for her parents as she
knows about the recent attack on ryan
and knows it could happen to jeff she
just tells him to be careful the next
email from elizabeth is to
judy it seems she wanted judy's help
with the bd but since judy's hands were
full whether that was a real or fake
excuse she didn't take the job and gave
her our credentials instead so that
explains how elizabeth got our number in
the first place we'll have to thank judy
for the job later but we got more to
look at first the last message is
similar to jeff's last message
it seems the couple was in agreeance to
fire leah but for some odd reason she
wasn't fired and jeff claims to not
remember their conversation at all
eric once again claims it was stress and
that it slipped his mind
on the wall is two degrees it seems that
both elizabeth and jeff were both
graduates from asukaga law school
quite the impressive degree the other
door leads to the main bedroom we can
see a recently fired militech pistol
that is
elizabeth's this is a bit weird jeff
claims that he shot his pistol the scan
says that it was recently fired which
probably means it was the one during the
break-in so how was this
jeff's and elizabeth's pistol we could
chalk this up to two things
it could either just be the family gun
shared by the couple thus making it bolt
theirs but then that leaves the question
of why there's so much emphasis on who
possesses the gun or
ultimately one of them is lying next to
the gun is a wedding photo where we see
a backdrop of red roses
elizabeth claims that they're blue but
we correct around the statement saying
that they're actually red i'll bring
this conversation up later but keep this
in mind as it's very important when we
talk to elizabeth we can question her
about jeff
passing out but once again nothing to
help us figure things out back outside
into the hallway we discovered
bloodstains that weren't covered
up completely as well as bullet holes
while it's not out of the ordinary
considering what occurred
why are they covered this means someone
willingly tried to hide this meaning
jeff did a lot more than just snuggle
back into bed after passing out or
someone here is lying
on the ground floor the same floor we
were on during our talk with the couple
we see a bowl of fresh fruit at least
they're trying to eat healthy and not
just fast food we also find a room with
a couple more computers this seemed to
be elizabeth's old office before the
election this explains why she has a new
tiny room
seems she got kicked out in place of
security on the desktop on the left it
has some messages we can read
the first is wallace addressing the new
recruits it seems that there's three
teams
blue black and orange team orange is the
new recruits and they have access to the
entire
penthouse except sector zero this is
only for blue and black team
and they are told if they see one of
them during the night do not engage with
any of the team members no matter what
unless specifically told to it ends with
follow the above rules and will ensure
for the continuation of the operation
and the security of our vps
isn't the operation the security of the
vps why is this separately mentioned it
shouldn't need to be
next is an urgent update apparently one
of the members of blue team was injured
by a target
alpha as for the follow-up email we get
a code to sector 0 which is 6709
as well as the confirmation that the
agent is being treated by a rescue team
coming to the location
we can use this code to open the desktop
next to us these two messages talk about
the security camera being scrubbed clean
of footage and how the agents know of
our arrival to the premises
thanks to a target alpha calling us wait
a minute
jefferson called us for this quest
target alpha
is jefferson it wasn't an intruder it
was one of the guards
so they knew about the attack and tried
to cover up the evidence by scrubbing
the feed and patching up the holes
now we have to figure out what this
sector zero is from this computer we
also open a door which is possibly the
door that leads to sector zero
as well as finding some files that were
deleted it seems they really wanted to
cover
all of their tracks upstairs is another
room with blood near it seems like this
is our sector zero
we go through the open door and we see a
whole setup of computers and a window
but wait a minute that wasn't there when
we passed by
so it seems they have a one-way mirror
so they can spy on the couple who are
these supposed guards anyway elizabeth
is shocked at the news and needs to sit
down leaving us to investigate
inside is a box of bloodied medical
supplies probably from the agent
bandaging himself
up and the computer has even more
questionable information
the first entry is about jeff's stress
levels and recommending
neural dampening entry 993 is about jeff
calling us for help and that an
emergency maintenance should be put
in place it also seems like we were
spotted by orange team on the way up
according to 995.
the last message is the suspension of
their operation called condon which
talks about the shooting in the injured
agent this is just more evidence to put
against the security behind us is some
wires that lead to the ceiling
if we follow these wires they'll lead to
a satellite according to johnny it's an
old militech transmitter it can only be
used when in direct line of sight of a
receiver but it cannot be intercepted
the receiver is near a van about a
couple blocks away
when we question elizabeth on the
transmitter she's confused it seems like
she's never seen this before and
security probably put this there without
them knowing
before we leave to see what this van is
doing near the receiver elizabeth tells
us not to mention this to jeff
immediately upon arriving we see the van
and it bolts off we can't get much off
of our scan only knowing that it's got
lots of hardware inside no manufacturer
info or modifications made to the
vehicle so they're hiding a lot of
information from us
the vehicle stops in an alley near some
maelstrom gang members we clear them out
then
jack into the van only to find the real
truth they were tracking
everything medical records height weight
neuroplasticity symptoms and tons more
it seems they both had symptoms of
severe memory loss we see fresh neural
links inside the parallas heads that
were controlling their minds
they're planting memories in their heads
and it's only getting bigger and bigger
with each scan
they have changed them in every way it
seems like there's also some more people
besides just the couple in their
database and a very diverse cast at that
as well
some having funds as high as 5 million
and as low as 8 000 in their bank
accounts
before we get a chance to download the
data it's all wiped and deleted but this
explains
everything their security was sent to
brainwash the couple and change them for
whatever reason this explains the
confusion of the gun in the room
why elizabeth forgot the rose color in
her wedding photo why jeff passed out
why one of their employees was set to be
fired but
wasn't but i think the most shocking
part is jeff himself we know they're
changing his memories how do we know
that his policies are true to his
beliefs
i'm thinking of two things these guards
clearly aren't some typical guards they
had the equipment and knowledge to pull
something like this off either they used
this brainwashing technique for
during or after the election think about
his campaign he wants no corporate
funding and an end to the corporate rule
in the city clearly the mega corps
wouldn't like that so these corpse
either hired the guards to gather info
on him to use in the election to help
holt or
they're the ones running in the election
think about it the people in night city
hate corpse that's why people would vote
for perales what if this was the plan
all along and the moment he becomes
mayor they flipped the switch so to
speak and now his memories are flooded
with ideas that instead help the
corps even more so either they're doing
this to make him lose or doing this to
trick the people and enforce their rule
even more
maybe it's both maybe the second idea
was a backup plan and they want holt to
win but just in case jeff does win they
have their backup plan
it wouldn't explain why there's more
people in their database but maybe
they're brainwashing people for
different reasons we call elizabeth and
tell her the details and she tells us to
meet in person at a japantown diner to
discuss the incident further she tells
us that a while ago she noticed these
changes in jeff's behavior he stopped
reading he forgot his favorite movie
changed musical taste overnight and even
claimed he was an only child despite
having a brother who recently passed
away
she also mentioned she was noticing
herself changed too it's hard for her to
pinpoint why but she claims that that
sealed room that we discovered is
familiar to her but as we noticed from
her reaction it sounded like it was the
first time she saw the room
she also mentions that she saw someone
tinker with the computer in their room
but had no clue if it was real or not
and because she saw nothing from the
security feed she thought she was going
insane again the story gets more scary
as she received a call from someone she
calls
them a person with a garbled voice
called her and said that her perfect
life would be ruined if she didn't
comply
we're then presented with two options
tell jeff the truth about what's going
on or go along with elizabeth's lie
which is to tell him that ssi was spying
on them for holt so he could win the
election by getting dirt on jeff
we meet at a nearby park and talk if we
go along with the lie about ssi jeff is
met at hull and plans to win the
election and quote unquote bury him with
all the dirt he's gonna gather on him at
the end we do receive some ending text
messages jeff says that they're gonna be
moving homes he plans to take this game
to a whole other level and is happy he
went with his gut to hire us
elizabeth thanks us for going on with
the lie and is happy that her family is
safe
jeff deletes our contact info and
elizabeth blocks us as to not draw
suspicion to
them that mysterious group of people we
can opt to go back on our statement and
text jefferson that we do have more info
and we are actually lying but it doesn't
matter as he's already deleted our info
we can't go back and change our mind if
we don't follow what elizabeth tells us
and instead tell jeff the real truth
jeff doesn't believe the truth at first
asking if this is some metaphor or joke
we tell him it's no joke and that they
want him as their mayor he tells us not
to worry as he's going to play along for
now then screw him over later when the
time comes
as for the text elizabeth is pissed at
us for now putting her family's life at
risk and we get no text from jeff but if
you have done the quest you know that we
aren't done yet
moments before our talk we get a call
from an unknown number that knocks us on
our ass
they tell us in a garbled voice it
doesn't matter what we say then that
nothing
can be changed they seem to know who we
are what we are and
what we want possibly referring to the
biochip in our head which would explain
the black vision and the knockout we
receive when we answer their final
statement is don't cross the line
these are probably the same people who
called elizabeth but that's not all
as nearby on a balcony we can see a
figure watching us could just be a
random npc but upon closer inspection
and a scan it's mr blue eyes from the
path of glory ending
coincidentally in the same ending we
also hear that jeff became mayor by
winning 70
of the vote this is twice he shows up
with jeff involved and the only two
times we see him in the game
the one ending out of all the endings
given to us the one
ending where perales becomes mayor we
see mr blue eyes and now the other time
that we talk to him
we also see him this is no coincidence
the two times that we see mr blue eyes
in the game in person
somehow jeff is involved there's no way
that's a coincidence he's either most
likely the caller that knocked us on our
ass or at least works for that
caller the voice on the call is garbled
so there's no way to cross-reference
their voice lines
could this be the ultimate plan for mr
blue eyes and his organization by
winning the election by brainwashing
peralas and reaping the benefits of it
johnny at the end
thinks it's not humans doing this but
ais there has been some talks about
rogue ai in cyberspace so it's possible
that this is what it is so that begs the
question
is mr blue eyes an ai but now in a body
is he a human but working for them or
maybe they brainwashed him completely
making him their human contact outside
the net it leaves us with a ton of
questions and zero answers
and i'm totally on board for this
mission to get expanded in the future
whether the perales storyline gets more
quests in a dlc or this whole ai
controlling people part is expanded on
for the entirety of the dlc with that
though we have come to the end of the
video and finished the paralysis
storyline arguably one of the best side
quests in cyberpunk 2077. let me know
your thoughts on this in the comments
down below i plan to talk more about mr
blue eyes in a future video to gather
all the info
we have on this guy and what we know
about him and his organization if you
enjoy these deep dive side quests videos
like the video to let me know and
subscribe for more in the future with
that though
take care everyone and goodbye
[Music]
you